in die brennende ukraine gießen die usa
weiteren treibstoff und fordern zudem
china auf mehr zu tun das feuer zu
löschen
das ist die sicht der chinesischen
staatszeitung global times das
staatsfernsehen berichtet vor allem
moskaus sicht der dinge übernimmt
kriegspropaganda und ungeheuerliche
behauptungen wie die des russischen
verteidigungsministers nach der
angebliche ukrainische nazis an
gefangenen kriegsverbrechen wie die
deutschen im zweiten weltkrieg verüben
die propaganda maschinerie läuft
präsident hält vladimir putin in seinem
überfall auf die ukraine bisher den
rücken frei china hat den einmarsch
russlands nicht verurteilt im un
sicherheitsrat enthielt sich china bei
der abstimmung eine resolution gegen den
einmarsch forderte verhandlungen
sanktionen lehnt china ab
die praxis hat längst gezeigt dass
sanktionen nicht nur keine probleme
lösen sondern auch neue schaffen was
nicht nur zur gegenseitigen vielfachen
wirtschaftlichen verlusten führt sondern
auch den prozess der politischen
einigung behindert
vor drei wochen hatten putin und
demonstrativ eine strategische allianz
besiegelt und fordern den westen vor
allem die usa und die nato heraus doch
china ist zunehmend in einem dilemma es
propagiert selbst die souveränität von
staaten und ist auf die
wirtschaftsbeziehungen mit dem westen
angewiesen auch in peking verfolgen die
menschen die ereignisse
china könnte vermitteln am besten ist es
nicht zu kämpfen
auf russischer seite haben sie keine
alternative die ukraine und weißrussland
sind die barriere zwischen russland und
der nato sie brauchen eine pufferzone
china und russland mit seinem krieg
tastet putin diese strategische allianz
wie gut sie hält hängt auch vom
zusammenhalt des westens ab